We have the example of Safia, the wife
of the prophet. May Allah be peace with
her.
According to Imam Anawi, she was the
most intellectual woman of a time. We
have the example of Om Salma, the wife
of the prophet, may Allah be pleased
with her. According
to Ni,
she
has taught no less than 32 different
scholars.
We have the example of Fatma
who once had a discussion with other may
Allah be pleased with him and other
Aisha may Allah be pleased with her for
asked together and yet they could not
prove her wrong. They could not
character she could not change the view.
She was so much knowledgeable.
We have example of um Dartha who was the
wife of our buda.
According to Mama Noi she was an
intellectual woman of a time. We have
the example of
Safia,
>> may Allah be pleased with her. According
to Immobi,
she was the teacher of Imam Shafi. Imam
Shafi,
may Allah have mercy on him. One of the
great imams.
Her he I mean she he
acquired knowledge from Safia bintash.
You also have example of Aisha bin Tad
Abi Wakas
the daughter of the famous Ahab Sad Abu
Wakas. She's said to have taught Imam
Malik who was another Imam great Imam.
So we have number of examples of females
who were scholars.
Let's discuss the legal rights of the
woman in Islam. Legally men and women
are equal.
According to the law of kas surah bakar
chapter 2 verse number 11 17
n that if
someone if a man kills a woman the man
is put to death like how a woman kills a
man the woman is put to death. It's a
law of kas. The punishment for man and
woman is the same in Islam.
And we have the example when a Jewish
woman at the time of the prophet
was killed by a man. The prophet ordered
the man to be killed. We have the
example at the time of may Allah be
pleased with him. The second khalif of
Islam. There were a group of men who
collectively were involved in the
killing of a woman. Hazat may Allah
please with ordered all the men to be
put to death.
In Islam,
the kiss for a part of the body whether
it be the ear, the nose, whatever
compensation is there for a man, the
same is there for a woman. And if
someone wants to take diya money, blood
money
of the person who has been killed,
even if it's a woman and if she's a
relative, she has the right to take diya
money. No one can object. That mean
legally men and women are same.
Allah says in the Quran in surah maha ch
5 verse number 38 as to the thief beat a
man or a woman chop off his or her hand
as a punishment from Allah. That means
if someone robs someone steal and all
the rules of the Shar applicable
irrespective whether it's a man or a
woman the punishment is the same
chopping of the hands. Allah says in
surah chapter 24 verse number two as to
the fornicator be it a woman or a man
each one should get 100 lashes. If
someone does fornication whether woman
or man the punishment is the same 100
lashes.
Allah says in surah chapter number 24
verse number four if anyone lays an
allegation against the modesty of a
woman and cannot produce four witnesses
lash the person with 80 lashes
and if in crossexamination
if any of the four falter all four of
them and the accuser get it lashes. This
is the law. You cannot play hanky panky
with the modesty of woman. In today's
world, people abusing women. They're
giving abuses in the name of your
mother, sister. What is this? In Islam,
if anyone lays an accusation against the
modesty of a woman cannot get four
witnesses, 80 lashes.
This is how the women are well protected
legally in Islam.